bei diesem lockdown leid wie ihn manche
nennen ist ja eines der merkmale dass
die schulen und kitas offen bleiben
dürfen
inwiefern hat das jetzt auswirkung
schulsystem bisher in deutschland wie
gut funktioniert das jetzt gerade
ja ich fürchte dass es nicht gut
funktioniert also grundsätzlich sind
auch wir als der lehrer verband jaaa
dafür dass schulen möglichst lange offen
gehalten werden aber wenn man dann einen
lock down hat muss man heute dann an den
schulen wenn wir sie offen halten will
besonders viel für den klimaschutz tun
und das geschieht leider nicht und die
konsequenzen merken wir jetzt die zahl
der schüler in quarantäne und der lehrer
in quarantäne und auch die infizierten
sollen die man heute dramatisch zu eine
der großen kritikpunkte war das im
gegensatz zu vielen gastrobetrieben oder
anderen unternehmen die schulen trotz
der jetzt längere zeit nicht gut genug
vorbereitet waren auf den herbst vor
allem nur stoßlüften und masken das
konzept wein inwiefern stimmt dass wir
ein hätten die einzelnen ländern noch
mehr an den schulen vorher tun müssen
ja ich glaube dass die politik einen
schweren fehler gemacht hat sie hatten
nämlich damals im märz als der lok dann
kommt die schulen eigentlich aus dem
blick verloren also man hat geschaut was
ja auch nicht verkehrt war als die
wirtschaft aus die reiseunternehmen auf
die luftfahrt unternehmen
kurzarbeitergeld et cetera aber man hat
nicht gesehen dass bildung extrem
wichtig ist dass schule für kinder
wichtig ist und dass man hier massiv
investieren muss egal ob das jetzt
digitalisierung betrifft oder etwa die
luft luft reinigungs filteranlagen aus
die wir jetzt schon lange vergeblich
warten an den schulen all das an da
hätte man früher gas geben müssen
jetzt haben sie gerade angesagt die zahl
der infizierten steigt auch an den
schulen wieder eines der worte salami
lockt an was genau ist damit gemeint
naja also ihr lieben natürlich jetzt
nahezu niemand die diskrepanz zwischen
dem versprechen der politik schulen
offen zu halten und dem
infektionsgeschehen vor ort nachdem die
politiker abschied genommen hat von
stufen plänen also keine verschärfung
und die gene maßnahmen mehr systematisch
in deutschland mehr folgte wird nur noch
geschaut vor ort infektionsfall gerste
in quarantäne
welche lehrer sind betroffen und das
zeigt halt das unabhängig von der
ankündigung der politik immer mehr
schulen entweder teilweise oder ganz
schließen müssen immer mehr kerzen in
quarantäne gehen immer weniger vom
gesamten unterrichts umfang dann auch
vermittelt werden kann
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren